Western weapons
in eastern Ukraine
they're evening up the battlefield for
Ukrainian troops against Russia's much
larger Army
but neither side stocks are infinite
and a race is on to see who can re-arm
fastest
on Ukraine's front line near the city of
bakmut a soldier explains how this
makeshift cover protects his gun from
Russian suicide drones
he also talks about the need to preserve
ammunition
um
the rate of artillery fire over the past
year has been greater than at any time
since the Korean War
a Ukrainian officer has told Sky News
that Russia had been firing 60 000 to 70
000 shells a day a level that's about
halved as supplies ran down
U.S officials have put that top rate at
around 20 000 a day but also say it's
dropped
Ukraine by contrast has been firing five
thousand to six thousand rounds daily
as for the impact Russia has lost around
9 000 pieces of military equipment such
as armored vehicles and artillery three
times more than Ukraine
with its tanks missiles and generosity
the UK is one of the Ukrainian
military's most important suppliers
but for how long I've been told Britain
is reviewing the size of its ammunition
stockpiles because Russia's Invasion
here has exposed how past assumptions on
what would be needed to fight a war were
far too conservative my sources say
Richie sunac must increase defense
spending to fund a massive expansion in
ammunition and weapon stores or risk
being unable to keep supporting Ukraine
at the level needed
rebuilding the UK's military strength
after Decades of cuts is also critical
the Prime Minister talked tough when he
hosted Vladimir zelensky this month
but one Whitehall Source accused Mr
sunac of having no interest in defense
and security those charged with that in
number 10 can barely get access to him
the president zelenski visit was engaged
with late and with only peripheral
passing interest if it's not domestic or
economic it doesn't feature
a Second Source said he's a financier
and simply can't understand these things
a government spokesperson said these
claims are baseless and untrue it was
the Prime Minister who as Chancellor
agreed the 2020 spending review that
provided the ministry of Defense with
the largest increase in defense
investment since the Cold War
the prime minister is clear that we will
do everything necessary to protect our
people which is why our Armed Forces
will always have the equipment and
capability they need
of course the UK is only one of many
countries arming Ukraine but dwindling
stockpiles is a common theme that needs
fixing so the troops can keep firing
their brain Sky News Kiev